DE THE HOUSERY
CHIEF LEL ANALYST AND FODERAL P
-E THAT WE'LL TA A LITTLEED
DON'T PROSECUTLD, Y, JEFFREY?
CRHAECSEED ON THE AVAILABLE EVEO
MMWAS HIS HA, OUTRAGEOUS,
WAF HE REMAINEINOFFICEROEEN BL
QUIREM RENT, LAW IS
REGARDING ACTIAT
WHAT THE CRIMINAL LA AND
SO FAR BASEDE IDENCE I DON'T THE
ANYTHING YOU COULD PROSECUTE
TRUMP F. M?ELL, BRIANNA, IT'ST
BE BACK WITH YOU WH MY OLD
FRIEND JEFFREY TOOBIN.WHAT H IS
WILL WAKE YOU UP IN THE MORNING,
BUT IAS TOTALLY ONG.
RIGHT NOW WE LIV SYSTEM
WHOUR
ONE IS ABOVE THE LAW.
IFGE
DISCOVERIDG, OF COURSE HE
SHOULD BE INVESTIGATED AND
PREC
EVIDENCEO PREDICATE AN TO OPSUBL
WHEN YOU HAVE A PRESIDENWHSAYS F
UST FIND OR
SAYS TO HIS OWN ACTINGY L, JUST
WAS CORRUPT AND LEAVE TH
TO ME.
E THF O KNOWS
>> WHAT'
NORM --
>>F, I -POTENTIALLY ALL I'M ARGT
GENERAL SHOUESTIGATE IT.
INWRHERE'S LIT TEV
L CRIMESEL
D,BSAN
CEEDING, A
CONSPI TD THE UNITED
IT MUST BE INVESTITEF. IESTIGAT
DEFRAUD,
YOE THATIREMENTS.THEY HT SAY
ECIFIC INTENT CRIME, T TUSUALLY
YOT THT WHAT THEY DOED
ONALD TRUMP DID WAS IN
PLAIN SIGHT.
AND FOR BETTER OR WORSE, EVERY
INDICATIONS ATLY
BELI TT THERE WAS FRAUD IN
SO TELLI PE TO INVESTITEFRAUD D.
S SPEECH O
NUERE LET'TO THEIT, LET'S BE
STRONG. Y THESHFOR?
JEFFYOU WANT TTHAT
NG THE TRUOTE IN OUR OP-ED
SEEKING TOPHAN TO BELIEVE HIM.
WE'RE NOT GOING TOERSON WH,0
FOR THE FIRST TIMEAND I THINK I
PLAUSIBLE AND MORE THAN
AUOUGHOR
ATTORNEYO OPEN
INATION THAT WHEN DONALD
TRUMP SAYS TO THE GEORGIA
SECRETARY  STATE, JUST
CO THE REST TO
LOOK AT THRIUS GROUNDSHIS
HE KW WAIS
HE'S A SERIA
OF COURSE, WE SHOULDN'E
THAT. AUT OFF
AN INVESTIGATION, HOW CAN YOU
Y THERE'LIEASO ATENERAL
INVEIG
AND, JEFF,O  ABOUT
E PROSECUTE THIS KIND
>> O HE OSECUTEDIC THEUNITED ST
>> DONALD P E
YOU KN
TE IS
FROM STUFFING BA BOX --
>>OU
>> JEFF, EXC
NEVER HAVE WRITTEN THERE IS
N TO EVEOP A
YOR.INAL INVESTIGATHAT IS WRONG.
YOU WERE AERTAINLY W E TH, YO,
THERE, INCLUDING YOUCLUDING
MANY PEOPLO
TRUMD
>> N ITEUMP.
ED ON  I WKE
HITION, JEFF.
LUNTEERED TOP BEFO
A CROOK HE
I DO NOT HATE DONALD TRUMP.
I DO NOT LIVE WITH H
ANYONE.
I THINK ON TO
BELIEVE HE VIOLATED LAW, ANDE S.
JEFF, THIS IS THE UNITED STATES
OF.
ABE
H STON --
KNOWORE ABOUAT
YOOWT
LIKE BEHIND THIR CURTAIN.
ONOF T OOTIC COUNTRIES IS WHEN
PEOPLE.PLE COM THE
COUNTRY THAT WN' THAT.IPS AND DI
>>> NO
ABOVE THE LAW.NO ONE, YOU KNOW,L
BUT YOU SHOULD PROSECUTE
PEOPLE I UNLES
SOLUTELY SURE.
SHOULDOU?
SHOULD YOU I TM? THALD P SHOULD
BU IHER.IMES HE WAS HING.
D IT'STANT FOR THE
LIHIS Y THATE THAT POWER WHEN
THERISBSR  OF VIOL
W.
I DON'T SEERI DON'T THINK WE'REE
IT HERE.
AND I THINK AT'S A VERY
ENT SCIOIMPEACHMENT.EFU SAIDW A
LOT ABOUISMAYBE MY KIDS HAD BEE
THINGS ON SOCIAL MY
AMBASSA COUNTRY  D SERVED AS
SERVED AS ANR IN A COUNTRY WHER.
I LEARNED ANOTHER LESSON THERE,
JEU HAVE TNCE THIS
PRINCIPLE THAT WE DON'
- IT'S A
WE DON'T NLLY PROSECUTE
YOU HTONCE IT AGAINST THE LAW .
AND IT IS -- IT WOULD BE EVE
WOULD LEADDY EE  EVIDETH
PROSECUTED AS MRFORMON OZZIE M
O
SAME THING, THE SAME KINOF
CONDUCT THAT TRUMP IN, T ON A S.
IT WOULD B
WORSE  PROSECUTING AN EX-PRESID
CODENCE THAT THE
SAME CRIMES HAD BEEN COMMITTED.T
FI JUST SAY THE
BALANCE THE CIAT NO ATTORNEN
PROBLEM WITH WHAT  SAYING
IS YOU ARE ASSUMING FAS THAT
DON'T EXIST YET.RE, YOU
INVEATESF
INT S WRITINOUT IS WHAT TH
MPOMCRIME.S NOT EVIDENCE TT
WAYS SAY LET'S E D THING,S NOT U
TH'S, THAT'S NOT EVIDENCE.
DENC IS.HE
TERRIBLE SPEECH. - BEHAVED BADLT
HIS ATTORNEY GENERAL.
T A CRIME?
GOINTO DONALD TRUMP IN
YOU WANT TO
VE THA TFOR
THE NEXTRS
ONLY STORY THAT ANY OF
THE COCUTED?I DON'T THINK SODOH
I DON'T THINK THERE'S EVID SUPP.
JUST FIND -- LETNISH, AVE,OOHAVE
LET ME FINISH.
H.
HOLD ON.
LET ME FINISH.-
EVIDENCE, JEFFGIA.OUT THDERAL
JUST SAY ELECTION WAS MENT TO G.
CORRUPT AND LEAVE THE REST TME .
LET ME JEFF.
IT'WH Y
WRLEEA OPEN A CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION.
AT LEASTAK JEFF.
OF COURSE, THEY
GENERAL -- HE HA
EVIDENCE OF CORR HERE.ING THE T?
SHOULD TAKE A HARD LOOK AT
S  EMAILS TOADE COTR TO LOOK BA.
OTEV OUT, WIES,
IF WE TOOK YCIPLE,E
COULD NEVER INVESTIGATE A WHIT
SO T ADMISE.
WEO SAY THERE'LIASON ETON CRIMI
VEIE>> YOU JUST N WHMENTS OF IF
THERE IS EVIDENCE OF IF
THERE T. IE IS EVIDENCE
THAT DONALD TRUMP WA